- [Narrator] This is the Facebook logo.
This is a pile of tobacco.
Why?
Because at the recent Facebook hearings,
we've heard a lot of this.
- Facebook is just like Big Tobacco,
pushing a product that
they know is harmful
to the health of young people.
- Facebook has taken
Big Tobacco's playbook.
- The tobacco industry--
- Big Tobacco--
Big Tobacco--
- All right. So you get it.
Members of Congress really
like this comparison,
especially around the impacts and harms
of social media on kids.
And if you look back at
the hearings of the 1990s,
where the chief executives
of the biggest tobacco
companies testified,
you can see why it's a handy comparison,
but as I'll explain, an imperfect one.
- Do you believe nicotine
is not addictive?
- I believe nicotine
is not addictive, yes.
- Congressmen, cigarettes
and nicotine clearly do not
meet the classic definitions of addiction.
- I don't believe that nicotine
or our products are addictive.
- I believe that it is not addictive.
- [Narrator] And here we are
more than 25 years later.
- We certainly do not want
our products to be addictive.
- So I disagree with calling
our product addictive.
I also think that's not
how we build products.
- In our recent Wall Street
Journal, Facebook File series,
my colleagues revealed
internal company documents
that show that the company
knows its products cause harm,
including to kids.
Okay.
Factor tobacco.
Now, while it's a convenient analogy,
in some ways, it goes up in smoke.
For one, the tobacco
companies spent decades
concealing their research,
lying and covering up what they knew
and even more important, social media
does not cause lung cancer.
- The truth is that cigarettes
are the single most dangerous
consumer product ever sold.
- That's former democratic
Congressman Henry Waxman.
He led the Big Tobacco
hearings in the 1990s.
This is him now.
So tobacco and social media,
what do you make of this comparison?
- There's nothing good about tobacco.
It's the only legal product we have
that we know that kills
and makes people sick
and has no redeeming value.
Social media has pluses
and some big minuses.
- Facebook spokesman, Joe
Osborne, said in a statement,
"It's an absurd comparison.
Social media helps people connect
and small businesses thrive."
But looking at how lawmakers
came up with regulation
for this box may give us some clues
about how they might handle this box.
But to do that,
we have to look at the
similarities between the two.
The first we can call, hooking for profit.
The more addicted you are to smoking,
the more money tobacco companies make.
The more time you spend
scrolling Facebook or Instagram
and thus consuming ads,
the more money Facebook makes.
In the 1990s,
the tobacco companies denied
adjusting nicotine levels
to encourage addiction.
- The claim that Phillip
Morris secretly adds nicotine
during the manufacturing
process to keep smokers addicted
is false.
- [Narrator] And here we are in 2021.
- But I want to drill down
on this addictive element.
But isn't part of your business
model to have more eyeballs
for a longer amount of time
engaged using your services?
- Respectfully, Senator,
that's not actually how
we build our products--
- [Narrator] Then there's
the not sharing of research.
- You're the Chief Executive Officer.
What reason could you not
give us this research,
if it's been conducted?
- I have no problem giving
you any material we have,
if it's not in some way involved
in active litigation at this time.
- [Narrator] And here we are today.
- Will you disclose all of
the reports, all of the finds.
Will you commit to full disclosure?
- Yeah, I know that we have
released a number of the reports
and we are looking to find ways to release
more of this research.
I want to be clear that this
research is not a bombshell.
It's not causal research.
- This research is a bombshell.
- Now again,
the tobacco companies had
years of scientific evidence
of health impacts of their product.
In Facebook's case, the
company is in early days
of understanding the impacts
of its digital tools.
And it has already
shared some information.
And that's perhaps the
biggest link being made
between Big Tobacco and Facebook.
Hooking the kids early.
Though, I guess you could
say that of other companies
like junk food.
Maybe we should have done this whole video
about Facebook and junk food.
The most famous tobacco targeting to kids?
- (indistinct) medical association found
that 91% of the children,
three through six,
could match Joe with a Camel cigarette,
which means, Mr. Johnston,
the Joe Camel was as well
known as Mickey Mouse.
Do you still maintain
that Joe Camel cartoons
are not targeted towards children?
- Congressman Synar, when--
- It's a simple question, Mr. Johnston,
do you contend that it's not
targeted towards children?
- Clearly and absolutely.
But I can explain to you--
- [Narrator] The Facebook
documents published
by the Wall Street Journal
show that the company has
been thinking of more ways
to engage children.
One slide reads,
"leverage play dates to
increase growth/retention".
In her testimony to
Congress, Frances Haugen,
the Facebook whistleblower,
who gathered the documents that
informed the Journal series
made her perspective clear.
- They have to make sure
that the next generation
is just as engaged in
Instagram as the current one.
And the way they'll do
that is by making sure
that children establish habits
before they have good self-regulation.
- By hooking kids?
- By hooking kids.
- The Facebook spokesman said companies
that operate in a highly
competitive space,
including the Wall Street Journal,
make efforts to appeal
to younger generations.
Since those Big Tobacco
hearings in the 90s,
we've seen regulation and settlements
that have limited the use
and marketing of these,
especially to kids.
The Master Settlement Agreement of 1998
banned advertising targeted
at those younger than 18
and banned the use of
cartoons like Joe Camel.
Ultimately in 2009,
the FDA was given the right
to regulate tobacco products,
including the levels of nicotine.
- A very similar set
of parallel regulations
have to be put on the box
in order to protect children
from Instagram, from social
media in the same way
that our nation put laws on the box
to protect children against Big Tobacco.
- [Narrator] That's
democratic Senator Ed Markey.
He has drafted the Kids
Internet Design and Safety Act,
or the KIDS Act.
It aims to create new
protections for users under 16.
They get to the heart of what's addicting
about social media.
- We have to ban push notification.
We have to ban auto-play.
We have to make sure that
the algorithms can't be set
so that it's deliberately playing games
with the minds of children in our country
up to the age of 16.
- [Narrator] Then there's
the Children's Online Privacy
Protection Act, or COPPA 2.0,
which is also backed by Markey
and has gained bipartisan support.
It would extend the
current privacy protections
to 13 through 15 year olds,
ban targeted advertising to kids and more.
Beyond protecting the
children, others argue
for regulating social
media content algorithms
and adjusting section 230
the law that shields online
platforms from being liable
for harmful content posted on their sites.
But even if Congress agrees on all that,
it will still have to
contend with lobbyists
as it did with Big Tobacco.
- Facebook and other
social media companies,
they can buy just about every
lobbyist in Washington DC.
But when the subject of
children, of teenagers is raised,
they're in a position
which is indefensible.
- The Facebook spokesman
said that the company
is in support of regulation.
"It's time for Congress to act." He said.
This all now sits with the lawmakers.
And if tobacco regulation is our guide,
it could be with them for a long time.
(narrator sniffing) I reek of tobacco.